big reason why podcasting has exploded
it's so refreshing because it's the
polar opposite of the Tweet what you're
going to talk to this guy for a couple
hours everything has gotten shorter and
shorter and shorter and I think the
podcast represents a pendulum swing
backwards to something that's real that
has depth and emotion and I think
there's something in our
in our spirit that yearns for that
storytelling in a way that allows it to
breathe there's also this yearning for
authenticity right you put these
conversations up like they're imperfect
they're not edited they're not drilled
down to sound bites and if you spend a
couple hours with somebody it's intimate
and that person is ultimately gonna
reveal who they are there's something
real about it there's something honest
about it that I think is also quite
refreshing and I think that's why people
are connecting with the media